now that we've seen that as we take i to
higher and higher powers it cycles
between 1
i negative 1 negative i then back to 1 i
negative 1 and negative i i want to see
if we can tackle some i guess you could
call them trickier problems and you
might see these surface and they're also
kind of fun to do to realize that you
can use this the fact that i the powers
of i cycle through these values you can
use this to really on a back of an
envelope take arbitrarily high powers of
eye
so let's try
just for fun let's see what i to the
100th power is
and the realization here is that 100 is
a multiple of 4. so you could say that
this is the same thing as i
to the
i to the 4 times 25th power and this is
the same thing just from our exponent
property this is i to the 4th power
raised to the 25th power right if you
have something raised to an exponent
then that is raised to an exponent
that's the same thing as multiplying the
two exponents and we know that i to the
fourth that's pretty straightforward i
to the fourth is just one i to the
fourth is one so this is one so this is
equal to one to the 25th power which is
just equal to
just equal to 1. so once again we use
this kind of cycling ability of i when
you take its powers to figure out a very
high exponent of i
now let's say we try something a little
bit stranger let's try i to the
let's try it i to the 500 and first
power now in this situation 501 it's not
a multiple of 4 so you can't just do
that that simply but what you could do
is you could write this as a product of
two numbers one that is a multiple one
that is i to a multiple of fourth power
and then one it isn't and so you could
rewrite this 500 is is a multiple of
four so you could write this as i to the
500th power i to the 500th power times i
to the first power right you have the
same base when you multiply you can add
exponents so this would be i to the 500
and first power
and we know that this is the same thing
as i to the 500th power is the same
thing as i to the fourth power
four times what four times 125 is 500 so
that's this part right over here i the
500 is the same thing as i to the fourth
to the 125th power
and then that times i to the first power
times i to the first well i to the
fourth is one one to the one
twenty-fifth power is just going to be
one this whole thing is one and so we
are just left with we are just left with
i to the first so this is going to be
equal to i so it seems like a really
daunting problem something that you
would have to sit and do all day but you
can use this cycling to realize look i
to the 500 is just going to be 1 and so
i to the 500th one is just going to be i
times that so i to any multiple of 4 let
me write this generally so if you have i
to any multiple of 4 so this right over
here is well we'll just restrict k to be
non-negative right now k is greater than
or equal to zero so if we have i to any
multiple of four right over here we are
going to get we are going to get one
because this is the same thing as i to
the fourth power to the k power and that
is the same thing as 1 to the k power
which is clearly equal to 1. and if we
have anything else if we have i to the
4k plus 1 power i have the 4k plus 2
power we can then just do this technique
right over here so let's try that with a
few more problems just to make it clear
that you can do really really
arbitrarily crazy things so let's take i
to the
seven thousand three hundred and twenty
first power
now we just have to figure out
this is going to be some multiple of 4
ti
plus something else so to do that well
you could just look at it by sight that
7 320 is divisible by 4 you can verify
that by hand and then you have that one
left over and so this is going to be i
to the 7320
times i to the first power this is a
multiple of four this right here is a
multiple four and i know that because
any hundred is a multiple any thousand
is a multiple of four and each hundred
is a multiple four and then twenty is a
multiple of four
and so this right over here will
simplify to one sorry that's not i to
the eighth power this is i to the
first power
7 321 is 7 320 plus 1.
and so this part right over here is
going to simplify to
1 and we're going to be left with i to
the first power or just i let's do
another one
i to the
90 i to the 90
90 let me try something interesting i to
the 99th
i to the 99th power so once again what's
the highest multiple of 4 that is less
than 99
it is
it is 96. so this is the same thing as i
to the 96th power times i to the third
power right if you multiply these same
base add the exponent you would get i to
the 99th power i to the 96th power since
this is a multiple of 4 this is i to the
fourth and then that to the 16th power
so that's just one in the sixteenth so
this is just one and then you're just
left with i to the third power and you
could either remember that i to the
third power is equal to
you could just remember this equal to
negative i or if you forget that you
could just say look this is the same
thing as i squared times i
this is equal to i squared times i i
squared by definition is equal to
negative 1. so you have negative 1 times
i is equal to is equal to
negative i
let me do one more just
just for the fun of it
let's take i to the 38th power well once
again this is equal to i to the 36th
times i squared i'm doing i to the 36th
power since that's the largest multiple
4 that goes into 38 what's left over is
this 2
this simplifies to 1 and i'm just left
with i squared which is equal to
negative 1.